مخاوف من اعدام ناشطه ايرانيه بعد ماسا
امينه
والافران يقاومون تسلط طالبان بالفن
ورقصه جديده لشيرين تعود الى دائره الجدل
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بيران مشاهدينا وحشيه النظام واساليب
القمعيه ما بتنتهي ومن وقت ما انخفض الشعب
الايراني وقرر انه ينزل على الشارع ويعبر
عن رفضه لممارسات النظام صارت السلطات
الايرانيه تستخدم كل الوسائل حتى الاعدام
كمان لاخفاء اصوات المطالبه او اصوات
مطالبه باسقاتها وبعد تنفيذ عدد من احكام
الاعدام غردت الممثله والمنشطه الايرانيه
اثنين
على تويتر وعبر عن قلقا من احتمال اعدام
ارميت عباسي وهي احدى معتقلات الاحتجاجات
الميته عباسي من مواليد عام 2001 وكانت
قوات الامن الايراني اعتقلتها بشهر اكتوبر
في مدينه كرش وبحسب موقع هانا الحقوقي
يقال انه اعتقال العباسي صار بعد ناشرها
ببعض المواد في الفضاء الالكتروني
على كل حال عن هاي القصه وعن استمرار
الاحتجاجات في ايران تنضم الينا من
بروكسيل الباحث في الشان الايراني
مناسلاوي اهلا فيك يا ست منى معنا ست منى
يعني واضح بانه بالفعل اساليب ال النظام
الايراني عم تزداد
قسوه وبشاعه يوم بعد يوم وعم نلاقي انه
احكام الاعدام عملها بتصدر بحق حتى يعني
صغار السن بشكل غير انساني ابدا عم نشوف
عم نحكي عن صبيه ممكن انها همم يعني ينفذ
بحقق همم حكم الاعدام وهي عمرها بس 21 سنه
كيف نقدر نفهمه هل هناك اي طريقه لوقف هاي
الممارسات الايرانيه البشعه
تحياتي لك وللمشاهدين يعني اول احب اعلق
على الميتا عباسي اول مره سمعنا اسمها هي
كان قبل شهر عندما اخذت الى مستشفى امام
علي من بواسطه قوات الامنيه انا ما يبدو
هي كان لديها نزيف داخلي وكان لديها تشقق
في مناطق يعني تبين انه كان عليها اثار
الاغتصاب الجنسي اللي تعرضت لها في في
السجون همم الرئيس المستشفى
قاموا بسرقه ارميته من الباب الخلفي من
المستشفى ورجعوها على السجن وهي في حالتها
الكارتيه ارميتها كانت بلوجر وكان لديها
يعني صفحه على اليوتيوب وانستغرام كانت
تنشر حياتها يعني هي كانت بالفعل تمثل
الشعب الحيويه شو المعلومات اللي نشرتها
على الفضاء الالكتروني اللي ممكن تودي
فيها لا حكم الاعدام بالفعل خصوصا اذا انت
بتقولي انه هي كانت اصلا ناشطه يعني بتنشر
اشياء عن حياتها مش اكثر
جمهوريه الانسانيه جمهوريه الاسلاميه
تتحكم في حياه المواطن يعني بمجرد هي تنشر
محتوى وهي غير محجبه تنشر محتوى وهي قد
تتكلم عن حقوق الانسان او حقوق المراه او
اساسا تعيش حياه خاصه تتكلم انه لدي
اصدقاء واحضرنا حفلات هذه تعتبر جريمه
ولكن هي بهذه الاحتجاجات كي هي بنت اخرى
همم يعني تعبت من الحياه تحت الضغط
عن رايها ان هي تدعم هذه هي الصوره او
الانتفاضه اللي ممكن الان نسميها بسبب
باستمرارها اكثر من 100 يوم هي تعتبر انها
يعني تعتبر جرينتها اللي اديت لها
اغتصابها تعذيبها لمده ثمانيه ايام بعدين
اجابها الى مستشفى سرقتها مره ثانيه
للمستشفى والان يعني هناك خطوره بعد شهرين
ان احنا ما نعرف ما هي ظروفها اللي
احتماليه اعدامها ولكن اود ان لانه اعدام
القاصرات القاصرات انا اتكلم ليست اول مره
ببدايه الثوره ايام خميني كان يتم اعدام
القاصرات البكر يعني اعمارهم تحت 18 سنه
رايت له منتظري اللي يذكر اسم بنت تاريخ
بانه وقفه وجه خميني ولم يقبل جرائم خميني
قال لهم لا يجوز قتل ال- ال- البنت
القاصره البكر اعدامها فرد كان من قبل
القوات الحرس الثوري سوف نقوم بالتزويجهن
فكان بهالدرجه من الوحشيه وغير انسانيه
اللي كانوا مثلا في يوم عزاء البنت اللي
كانت معدومه كان احد قوات الحرس الثوري
كان يروح ويذهب ويقدم لهم الحلو والورد
ويقول انا تزوجت بنتكم قبل الاعدام يعني
هذه التصرفات موجوده وموثقه انا لا اقول
قصص وحكايات يعني اهالي اهالي البنات
المعلومات ولكن مع الاسف يعني اللغه
الفارسيه نوع من التغطيه للجمهوريه
الاسلاميه لان احنا ايه او حتى يحصل في اي
دوله عربيه في 300 مليون يتكلمون
معلش اسمحي لي ست منى يعني في زمن السوشل
في ميديا ماضل في شيء بيخبط يعني كل ما
يحصل في اي بلد سيخرج للعلن وكل الناس راح
تعرفه ربما من ابرز الاشياء اللافته في
هذه الاحتجاجات او الانتفاضه الايرانيه هي
انه رغم هذه القعده ما ترغم الوحشيه
الكبيره اللي بيتعامل معها بيتعامل فيها
النظام مع شعبه الا انه هذا لم يثني هذا
الشعب وما زال حتى لم يثني او يخيف صغار
السن من قاصرين او حتى اكبر شويه من انه
يعبروا عن رئيس الاحتجاجات
يعني هذا السوشيال ميديا لان احنا نسمع عن
هذه الجرائم ولكن شعب الايراني عاش 40 سنه
لذلك ليست جديد عليه لذلك لا يتراجع لا
يخاف اسقط الخوف لانه صار له 40 سنه يعيش
هذه الامور قضيه الاقتصاد بالسجون ليست
اول مره يعني دائما مع الاسف بكل احتجاج
يحصل ولذلك اشخاص اللي رايحين على الشارع
يعرفون ما يحصل لهم وتعبوا من استمرار
الحياه وهكذا
تراجعوا سيكون هناك انتفاضه اخرى
مره اخرى شكرا جزيلا لك منى السيلاوي
الباحثه في الشان الايراني كانت معنا من
بروكسل شكرا
[موسيقى]
من ساعه ما استولت حركه طالبان على الحكم
بافغانستان قراراتهم المشفى بحق
الافغانيين عموما والنساء خصوصا ما بتخلص
وبعد ما كانوا منعوا الافغانيات من الظهور
على التلفزيون بدون نقاب الى جانب تخصيص
فصول دراسيه ومداخل بتفصل ما بين الجنسين
فجرت الحركه صدمه كبيره من ايام بقرار
جديد بيقول انه ممنوع التعليم الجامعي
للاغانيات القرار طبعا
من المنظمات الحقوقيه ومن المجتمع الدولي
حتى انه فنانين افغان ايضا عبروا عن رفضهم
للقرار لكن على طريقتهم الخاصه الفنان
الافغاني حسن رضى يختار صوره رمزيه لكن
بالحقيقه جدا معبره اعتراضا على هذا
القرار الفنان استخدام رساله وزاره
التعليم العالي للضمنت قرار منع
الافغانيات من التعليم الجامعي كغطاء لجسد
امراه مثل كانه كفن لها وزير التعليم
العالي التابع لحركه طالبان محمد نادين
كان امس اكدوا قال بمعنى انه لو ضربوا
الحركه بقنبله ذريه ما راح يتراجعوا عن
قرار منع التعليم الجامعي للنساء للاسف
الموضوع يا جماعه ما توقف هون بس ولكن
حركه طالبان ايضا مستمره بقراراتها واصدرت
مش من زمان طبعا اوامر لا المنظمات غير
الحكوميه في افغانستان تمنعها فيها من
تشغيل النساء وبررت قرارها انه الموظفات
ما عملهم بيلتزموا بقواعد اللباس المناسبه
وهدت بتعليق تراخيص المنظمات لو ما نفذت
القرار
من بدايه السنه واسم الفنانه المصريه
شيرين عبد الوهاب متصدر كثير مرات كمان
بالخط الاحمر سنه كانت فيها شيرين عم
بتعيش حياتها الشخصيه بكل تفاصيلها مع
العالم من لحظه اعلان انفصالها عن زوجها
حسام حبيب التي فيها من عائلتها لها
بالطاعاتي لدخلها المستشفى وصولا لاعلان
زواجها مره ثانيه من طليقه لكن جديد شيرين
هو فيديو ظهرت فيه بملهى ليلي بلبنان مع
زوجها حسام وابنتها وكانت بحاله سعاده ما
بتنصف خلونا نشوف مع بعض
ههه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مبسوطه كثير مثل ما شفتوا شيرين كانت عم
تتصرف بطريقه شوي غريبه او يمكن بعفويه
لكن العالم ما صدقت وشافت شيء جديد لشيرين
والموضوع عمل جدل ومجددا عرضها طبعا كثير
من الانتقادات الواسعه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي خلونا نشوف بعض هذه الانتقادات
اهلا من جديد ازمات سياسيه واقتصاديه
خانقه بيعيشها السودان بالفتره الاخيره
لكن الجديد انه شرطه مكافحه المخدرات
بالسودان ما بيمر اليوم بدون ما تعلن عن
ضبط شحنه مخدرات في العاصمه او في
الولايات لدرجه انه الموضوع وصل انه يتحول
لاخبار يوميه على منصات الاعلام الرسميه
وبعدين انتشار المخدرات بشكل كبير اطلق
مستخدمون لمواقع التواصل بالسودان هاشتاج
الحق ولدك لمحاربه تفشل المخدرات بالسودان
بسرعه عامه وما يعرف خصوصا بمخدر الايس
كريستال الفتاه واللي بيعرف كمان بمخدر
الشيطان على وجه الخصوص
طبعا عن هذه الحمله يوم مدام انتشار
المخدرات في السودان بتنضم لنا من الخرطوم
الدكتوره منى علي المستشاره في علاج
الادمان اهلا بك يا دكتوره منى معانا
دكتوره منى بدايه خلينا نحكي عن انتشار
هاي في السودان بالفعل ما مدى انتشارها
وتغلغل لها من بين الشباب لغايه لدرجه انه
يتم اطلاق هذا الوسم والهاش تاج ولدك
طيب اهلا وسهلا مساء النور معكم في قناه
العربيه المستشاره المستشاره لبنى علي
محمد عبد الرحمن خبير استراتي في علاج
الادمان مدير مركز غادرين لعلاج الادمان
وعدد التاهيل حقيقه الوطن
ان شاء الله طيب بالنسبه الكريستال عايز
حقيقي انتشر انتشار كبير جدا يمكن معروف
عالميا اي دوله في العالم يكون فيها مشاكل
بتاعت عدم استقرار امني ونزاعات وتظاهرات
موجوده في الدوله بالاضافه لان الخرطوم او
السودان بصوره عامه دوله متراميه الاطراف
يعني عندنا حدود مفتوحه في ثمانيه دول
الانتشار كميه كبيره جدا على مستوى
الولايات الخرطوم والولايات يمكن الولايات
الحدوديه كولايات كسل ههه
20 يوم كميات كبيره جدا دخلت الولايه
ويمكن للسهوله الحصول عليها اصبح الانتشار
كثيف يعني الجرام بتاع الايس ولايه كسره
باربعه الف جنيه في ولايه الخرطوم ب 18
الالحق ولدك هي الحمد لله بالضبط
ومدى خطورته لانه في يعني مخدرات انواع
كثيره مدى خطوره هذا تحديدا
طيب يوجد في السودان مخدرات كثيره من
ضمنها اللي هو البانجو او الحشيش اللي
بيزرع في محميه الردوم ولكن الخطوره
والفرق بين المخدرات الثانيه الايس من اول
جرعه ممكن الانسان يدمن اللي هو عباره عن
انفتامينات مرض الانفتامينات منها
الكبتاجون اكحبوب معروفه للناس يستخدم
الكريستال عالميا منذ الحرب العالميه اول
دولتين استخدموه وهي المانيا واليابان
للجنود عشان يسهروا مسافات طويله وكده لكن
دخل السودان بكميات كبيره من بعد الثوره
كان السودان زمان سابقا هو معبر للمخدرات
ايا كان الانواع بتاعته لكن ما حصل الان
في يوم من الايام من ان احنا متابعين اكثر
من غرفه عمليات شهر مصعد عمري منظماتنا ما
حصل يوم خطط الاخبار انه تم عبد غبيه
معينه سواء كانت الكريستال او الكبتاجون
او او البانجو او غيره انتشر ليه
كميه كبيره ولين نفسي اطلع اولا في اسباب
تعود للدوله في اسباب تعود للشباب
اللازوال بتعود للدوله البلد الوضع
السياسي غير مستمر الحدود المفتوحه
التحديات داخل السودان من النزاعات
والحروب كبيره جدا اكبر من الفتره الفاتت
همم بالنسبه للشباب العطاء العاليه جدا
جدا في احباط جدا وسط للشباب نحن الان
قاعدين في السيديو على البطاله الاحباط
السياسي خلينا نحددها يعني الاحباط
السياسي الان الناس قاعده في الاستديو
الان والمظاهرات بره وهم دول الشباب اللي
هم وعوده الثوره
الشتاني الفتره بتاعه الكرونه خلت العطاله
الزمنيه الطويله خلت الاسباب املس يعني ما
في هدف واضح في الحياه عشان يقدروا يعني
يغطوا الفتره بيتذكرون عالميا الرذيذ
السنه اللي حصل في زمن الكرونه ليس
السودان فقط كل الدول
الشده يعني خلى المشاكل الامنيه الموجوده
لانتشار بقى عالي خالص خالص او
فيتامينات اللي صنع انت قلتي الخطوره
الخطوره لانه ممكن يصنح في اي مطبخ
سهل التصنيع طيب دكتوره بالنسبه للحمله
الهاشتاج الحق ولدك واضح بانها يعني نوعا
ما موجهه للاهلي عشان يقدرون خط الدفاع
الاول يعني بالنسبه لابنائهم هن اللي
يراقبوهم وهن اللي يساعدوهم للتخلص من هذه
القفه هاتي لنا اكثر عن هذه النقطه وعن
همم كيف شو هي فعاليات هاي الحمله وكيف
عمته تنشر الوعي
طيب اولا احنا عابرين مؤسستنا بيتنا
بيشتغلنا لثلاثه سنوات في رفع التوعيه
الاجتماعيه زمان بنتكلم عن انه كيف تودي
ولدك المصحه عشان يتعالج الان الحق ولدك
مشكله لانه الكريستال ايز اصبح الان وسط
كله 10 متعاطيين ماده الكريستال ايس اصبح
يصاب اربعه منهم بمرض الكبد الوبائي وصدق
العلاقه انه العلاقه انه اصلا الحقنه اللي
بتطعن وبها متوفره زي شير زميل مشاركه
ما هي بتوزع الحقن المحقونه بالطريقه ديه
دي الخطوره الحادثه خلت الحاله اللي تخافش
ثاني الخرطوم ولا السودان بسرعه احنا ما
جاهزين اللي مراكز علاج بالكميه الكبيره
لانه ال- ال- العرض كثير او الطلب كثير
يمكن توجد ثلاثه مصحات حكوميه
الحمل الغرض منها توعيه الاهالي لانه يا
اخواننا اذا الاسره ما بقتيها صمام الامان
ما نقدر نعمل حاجه اكيد شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتوره لبنى علي المستشاره في علاج
الادمان كانت معنا من الخرطوم شكرا
[موسيقى]
انتهى كاس العالم في قطر بكل لحظاته
السعيده والحزينه في الملاعب فقط لكن لم
ينتهي حضوره في وسائل التواصل فبعد ما حقق
المنتخب الارجنتيني حلم قائده اللاعب
ليونيل ميسي بفوز على فرنسا بضربات
الترجيح وبعد ما تعادل كان سيد الموقف
بالوقتين الاصلي او التعادل كان سيد
الموقف بالوقتين الاصلي والاضافي تداولت
صفحات و حسابات على مواقع التواصل بلغات
مختلفه حول العالم منشورات بتقول انه
المصري في المركز الارجنتيني راح يصدر
عمله رسميه عليها صوره ميسي منشورات كثيره
الحقيقه صدرت المشهد وجابت مئات المشاركات
وعشرات الاف التفاعلات على صوره او صوره
لورقه نقديه من فئه الفايزو عليها رسم
لميسي وانه المصري في المركز في مونس
ايروس افضل هذه العمله تقريبا لميسي لانه
تمكن من تكرار اللي عمله امراته
لكن يا جماعه هل بالفعل المصرف المركزي
الارجنتيني اصدر عمله بتحمل صوره ميسي
بصراحه لا لانه بعد البحث والتدقيق بحقيقه
هذه المنشورات تبين انه الارجنتين ما
اصدرت عمله عليها صوره ميسي وما في اي اثر
لهذا الخبر من اي مصدر موثوق والموضوع ما
خلص لهون المتحدث باسم المصري في المركزي
فرناندو الونسو
ايضا هو بذات نفسه صرح وقال انه ما في اي
مشروع لاصدار عمله عليها صوره ميسي
نيجي لا شخصيه رياضيه اخرى في بعد ما صارت
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بشكل جزء كبير من
حياتنا صار اي شيء بدنا ننزله لازم يكون
كثير حريرين وعارفين منيح شو ممكن يعمل من
ردود افعال خصوصا اذا كان عندنا متابعين
بالملايين لحد هون نحنا عم نحكي بشكل عام
لكن موضوعنا عن نجم المنتخب المصري
وليفربول الانجليزي محمد صلاح صلاح قبل
بيوم نشر صوره هو وعائلته الصغيره امام
شجره عيد الميلاد بمنزله لكن بعدها الصوره
اثار محمد صلاح حيره متابعيه بفيديو جديد
بيطلع فيه على وشك القفز من طياره
هيلوكبتر مقطع الفيديو نشروه صلاح
باستخدام خاصي او نشر وصلاح باستخدام
خاصيه الاستوري على حسابه في الانستغرام
داخل استوديو تصوير قاعد بمدخل الطياره
وعلى وشك القفز وفي ناس من تحت بتشجعوا
على القفص خلينا نشوف مع بعض عن اي فيديو
يا صلاح
المقطع اثار حيره متابعين محبوب مصر
بخصوصا بخصوصا اذا كان المقطع هو جزء من
حمله دعائيه او من مسلسل درامي او من فيلم
سينمائي كان هناك كثير من الاسئله خصوصا
انه صلاح شارك بكثير من الحملات الدعائيه
للشركات وبيوت ازياء لكن الحيره كانت انه
صلاح بحياته وشارك في اعمال دراميه سواء
بالسينما او بتليفزيون ولحد الان ما في اي
رد من صلاح باكد او بينفل الموضوع
نيجي لاخر قصه مع نادي ديسمبر طبعا هو شهر
نهايه السنه وفعليا هو الشهر الفرح
والاعياد والهدايا لكن يا جماعه الهديه
اللي قدمتها جورجينا رودريغيز صديقه
اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
بمناسبه عيد الميلاد كانت صراحه من نوع
اخر رونالدو نشر صوره للهديه عبر حسابه
على انستغرام وهي عباره عن سياره من مركز
موجه الشكر لجورجينا جورجينا زي ما نشرت
فيديو كمان عبر انستغرام على حسابها اظهر
فرحه رونالدو الكبيره بعد ما كشفت له عن
هديتها في العيد
[موسيقى]
وهيك وصلنا مشاهدينا على ختام ااا تفاعلكم
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]